[Music]
with the release of guardians of the
galaxy volume 2
Marvel Studios has submitted the ability
to take pretty much any random character
in its vast publishing library and
turned it into a blockbuster event while
it's not surprising that the second
movie starring the Guardians was a hit
the movie then did raise some
interesting questions both within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as well as our
own much more boring terrifying reality
what kinds of questions please questions
dummy
dance-off fro me and you oh and before
we get into the real nitty gritty just
remember they're obviously spoiler to
happen ego on earth when star Lords dad
ego the Living Planet enacted his scheme
to take over the universe with big
blobby versions of himself we got a
glimpse of total chaos erupting in
Missouri on earth what we didn't see
however was the response of any of
Earth's many many super-powered people
Scarlet Witch Hawkeye the vision none of
the Avengers were anywhere to be found
even ant-man couldn't apparently be
bothered to put in an appearance said
lucky was there but was just like too
small for us to see anyway let's get
back on topic the lack of a super heroic
response on earth was conspicuous by its
absence so when it's ever will we follow
up on the giant blob lotion that
occurred in Missouri as a result of
quills crappy dad probably not in thor
ragnarok which seems to take place
almost exclusively away from earth
well Peter Parker flip past the news of
the disaster while he's watching TV and
spider-man homecoming we know that the
guardians of the galaxy will have some
sort of presence in the upcoming
Avengers infinity war so dealing with
the eagle blobs aftermath may give the
spacefaring heroes the excuse to get
involved with events on earth and while
we're on that subject
nebula on the hunt by the end of the
film Gamora sister nebula is essentially
a member of the guardians even if no one
really likes her very much but she still
leaves to punish Thanos for putting her
through hell her entire life actress
Karen Gillan has already confirmed that
she'll appear in infinity war so she
must be colliding with Thanos one way or
another once that movie debuts in 2015
and that's yet another potential way for
the guardians to get mixed up with the
rest of Earth's Mightiest Heroes
star-lords status we had hint that
star-lord had some pretty heavy-duty DNA
back in the first guardians of the
galaxy there have been plenty of little
ones but the biggie was what he held
onto the Infinity stone to defeat Ronan
the accuser and somehow didn't explode
into a million star bits ego made it
sound like the only thing keeping him
immortal was the Living Planet glowing
Brady core but is that you know true ego
said that none of his other children had
managed to retain their celestial powers
except for Peter
so that means ego would have no idea how
the powers of one of his children would
actually work after his own death right
moreover why would Peter lose his powers
just because it's deadbeat dad melted
into space dan if you get your dad's
blue eyes they don't fall out of your
head after you kick the bucket it's
entirely possible that quill is still
every bit the star-lord he was before
you go died on the other hand if he go
is right that opens up a whole different
can of space worms Peter quill spent his
whole life being well him but if he's
relied on his celestial powers to get by
in life up to this point
how will the sudden loss of those powers
affect him going forward romance by the
end of the movie we saw Gamora finally
hint that she may have the same feelings
for star-lord that he has for her but
beyond that where the relationship
between these two characters go is
anybody's guess conflict Drive stories
and as Peter pointed out when he
referenced Sam and Diane on Cheers
having the couple get together is
usually where the story and the
audience's interest in said relationship
ends don't be surprised to see that
there's actually trouble in paradise
between the two when they next appear
and maybe someone else could come into
the picture and throw a monkey wrench
into the relationship like say Star Fox
the legendary space lothario and younger
brother to a certain purple face jerk
named Santos and while we're on the
subject of romance no hero is necessary
in many ways the guardians of the galaxy
sequel confirms what we already knew
Marvel Studios doesn't need to rely on
the traditional superhero formula to
make great movies in fact this film was
probably one of the least heroic outings
the studio is released since the MCU
started sure the gang saved the galaxy
by being heroes but this movie had much
more in common with Ghostbusters than
Avengers and that's the thing Marvel
Studios has access to nearly every
character in the Marvel Comics library
and they published a whole lot of comics
over the years including cowboy comics
romance comics and even cowboy romance
comics back in the day Marvel Studios
simply needs to keep making good movies
to be successful it doesn't matter if
the characters they choose or
recognizable or not before guardians of
the galaxy who had ever heard of Drax
the destroyer or Gamora or Ronan the
accuser except for the geeks way in the
back of the comic shop if Marvel wants
to tap new genres featuring even more
obscure characters there's ample proof
that it can do so without too much risk
and doing new interesting things with
big-budget movies means audiences will
have more choice that's a win filmmakers
making films both guardians of the
galaxy movies were very much the product
of writer director James Gunn will
probably never know for sure how much or
how little input Marvel Studios had on
the script and final cut but these are
two very unique very weird very fun
movies just as Marvel Studios can branch
out into different territory when it
comes to the kinds of movies it releases
it seems as though the studio is
starting to truly trust its filmmakers
to deliver the goods in whatever form
they think it best fans definitely have
reason for concern when director Edgar
Wright left the ant-man production in
2014 due to creative differences but as
time goes on that incident seems more
like a fluke than anything's truly
worried about when it comes to Marvel
movies they'll probably be pretty good
no matter who's sitting in the
director's chair thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]